manney coachman is a real estate mogul
who is most known for his extensive
supercar collection has garnered have a
massive audience on YouTube from
Bugattis and McLaren Stu Rolls Royces
and cone execs many as the mall his car
is often changed as he constantly sells
and buys the latest cars but one thing
that doesn't change is the growth of the
value of his car collection so how much
money does Manny coachman actually make
to afford this many collectible cars
[Music]
well starting off with this income
sources though he does make money from
real estate YouTube and the super cars
appreciating most of his income is from
real estate so that's where we'll mainly
focus on in this video as for real
estate he has a two hundred and fifty
million dollar real estate portfolio
including both residential and
commercial properties to estimate his
revenue from this vast portfolio we will
use cap rates a properties cap rate is
the ratio between its net operating
income and its purchase price now cap
rate doesn't include debt repayment or
appreciation it simply tells you what
percentage you would profit every single
year if you were to own the property
outright for instance if you are looking
at buying a $100,000 house to rent out
and as a cap rate at seven percent this
means that you will profit roughly seven
thousand dollars every year after
accounting for vacancy property taxes
insurance maintenance and so on and so
forth cap rate accounts for everything
except for appreciation and financing
mani coachman who lives in Orange County
California with a median cap rate for
apartment buildings is four point one
five percent which is actually one of
the lowest cap rates in California but
just because many lives there doesn't
mean all of his properties are there as
well
he has properties in many Californian
cities and even a few properties in
neighboring states averaging out the
median cap rates of each county given in
this list we get an average cap rate of
five point four two percent for his
apartment buildings looking at his
office buildings the average cap rate
for suburban and urban office buildings
across North America is seven point two
nine percent and finally asked for
residential properties these properties
generally have some of the highest cap
rates however there is not much
information about median residential
property cap rates as cap rate is
generally a calculation you only use for
commercial properties but considering
that most of Minnie's properties or
apartment buildings or office buildings
anyways we'll just assume that as
residential property cap rates are also
quite similar if anything they'll be
higher than the commercial cap rates
averaging out the cap rates for the
apartment buildings and office buildings
we get an overall cap rate of six point
three five five percent but the estimate
conservatively we'll call it six percent
with two hundred and fifteen million
dollars in real-estate this will come
out to fifteen million dollars per year
but we know that he doesn't own all
these properties outright so he doesn't
actually get to directly keep all this
money in fact he likely has over a
hundred million dollars in debt as his
net worth is only 50 million which is of
course not small by any means but only a
fifth of the valuation of his real
estate portfolio but this isn't actually
a bad thing as this allows me to pay off
his properties and gain net worth
without being taxed and on top of that
he gets plenty of tax write-off from
carrying that much debt so really the
only downside of having debt on real
estate is the interest this can also be
used as a tax write-off to a certain
amount but commercial properties do have
much higher interest rates compared to
residential properties so interest is
definitely a bigger deal when looking at
commercial properties the average
interest rate for commercial properties
is five to seven percent so we'll say 6%
on average and as for how much Manny
borrowed when he bought these properties
he would have had to put down at least
fifteen to thirty five percent I don't
think he's looking to over leverage so
I'd say he put down at least twenty five
percent which comes out to sixty two
point five million down now you may be
wondering how would many be able to put
down sixty two point five million when
his net worth is 50 million well
the properties were likely much less
expensive when he actually bought them
so he probably doesn't have as much debt
as his calculation would suggest but
we'll stick with it to keep it
conservative looking at a principal paid
on chart for one hundred eighty seven
point two five million in loans their
interest paid per month ranges between
five thousand five hundred dollars and
nine hundred and thirty seven thousand
dollars as you guys probably already
know this is because a smaller and
smaller portion of your payment goes
towards interest each month over thirty
years the average interest payment per
month would be four hundred and seventy
one thousand dollars
or about 5.6 six million dollars per
year so his net profit per year from
real estate would be nine point three
three million but that's his principle
pay down and cash flow
we still have appreciation in California
has some of the best appreciation rates
in the entire country over the past 20
years California has an average annual
appreciation of four point nine nine
percent even assuming four percent this
were bringing another ten million in net
worth gained from real estate so many
makes a minimum of about twenty million
dollars per year from real estate but he
likely has higher cap rates upwards of
ten percent and it likely doesn't pay
nearly as much in interest every month
as the price he paid for his properties
are likely tens of millions lower than
what they are worth today
what's a ten percent cap rate 150
million dollar purchase price and
appreciation of five percent many could
be making upwards of thirty four million
dollars per year just from real estate
alone will less to be on the lower side
and call it 25 million moving on to his
YouTube income manny has quickly grown
on YouTube falling in four point three
three four million views this past month
but his videos are mostly for
entertainment as most people watching
this channel or watching to see him mess
around with supercars as opposed to
actually learn about real estate
so his CPM is likely on the lower side
at two to four dollars per thousand
views this would actually come out to
eight to sixteen thousand dollars per
month but this pills in comparison to
his real estate income and he is selling
a few courses but again even the
demographic of his viewers it's likely
that not many people actually buy his
courses now this isn't to say he doesn't
make money from his courses as I'm sure
he makes tens of thousands from them
every month but again this is not much
compared to 25 million a year as for
appreciating cars he has had a few
outstanding flips profiting millions
from single sales but these are far and
few between so if anything his YouTube
ad revenue course sales and other small
income sources would add up to five
million per year as a result
coachman's yearly income is roughly
twenty-five to thirty million dollars
and I think we all agreed that this is a
anyways if you're interested in how many
is able to pour so much into cars make
sure to check out my video about that
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one